in 2017 Samsung's revenue who was two
hundred and six point four nine billion
dollars samsung has over 300,000
employees then pull in $6,500 every
second and their construction team was
actually the people who built the Burj
Khalifa in Dubai which is the tallest
building in the world currently but
where does such a monstrous company come
from but before we get into that make
sure to subscribe to his channel if you
guys would like to see more origin
stories just like this one
samsung was founded by Lee Jung Cho in
1938 Lee was from a large land owning
family in you rank country and he found
a Samsung in a nearby city named Daegu
at first sab site was a simple small
trading company with just 40 employees
located in soo-dong they simply dealt
with dried fish and locally grown
groceries and noodles the company
flourished and Lee eventually moved its
head office to Seoul in 1947
unfortunately when the Korean War broke
out he had to leave Seoul meanwhile he
found her sugar refinery in Busan named
Caleb J ding furthermore in 1954 leave
founder chil logic and it became the
largest woollen mill ever in the country
Lee always wanted Samsung to be diverse
and a leader in a variety of fields and
as a result he experimented with
Insurance Securities and retail in 1947
Cho hunger Jae who was the founder of
the hyeongseong group and Lee got
together and jointly invested into a new
company named Samsung Molson gong saw or
Samsung Trading Corporation however soon
after they had differences in management
styles and he ended up splitting into
Samsung Group hyosung group Hankook Tire
and other businesses in the late 1960s
Samsung entered the electronics industry
and their first product was the
black-and-white television set later in
1980 Samsung quired Hankook jeon ja
toxin they were able to enter a tell
Communications Hardware line at first
they produced switch sports but soon
they got into telephone and fax
manufacture systems and eventually
transitioned into mobile phone
manufacturing today they have
manufactured over 800 million mobile
phones if we divide that equally among
the population that you'd see that one
in every 10 people have a Samsung phone
which is absolutely insane
anyways unfortunately there was some
trouble coming up for Samsung Lee died
in 1987 and Samsung Group was separated
into four business groups which were
Samsung Group Shinsegae group CJ group
and Hansol group since then these groups
still remain independent many
representatives and executives from
these groups have assured that they have
been completely independent from Samsung
since the split in the early 1980s
Samsung Electronics began to invest lots
of money into research and development
these investments are thought to be a
game-changer for Samsung and responsible
for bringing Samsung to the forefront of
global electronics industry for example
in 1982 they built a television subway
plant in Portugal in 1984 they built
another one in New York and then one in
Tokyo in 1985 one inland in 1987 and
then a huge one in Austin in 1996 as of
2012 samsung has invested more than 13
billion US dollars in the Austin
facility and this represents one of the
largest single foreign investments in
the u.s. in the 1990s samsung began to
rise as an international company and
have began diversifying beyond just
electronics for example samsung's
construction branch was able to build
one of the Petronas Towers in Malaysia
Taipei 101 in Taiwan and even the Burj
Khalifa in the United Arab Emirates in
1993 Lee kun-hee sold off many of
Samsung's subsidiaries and focused on
electronics engineering and chemicals
throughout the 90s Samsung achieved many
great feats in 1992 they became the
world's large
just producer memory chips and the
second largest ship maker after Intel in
1995 it created its first liquid crystal
in 1995 it created its first liquid
crystal display or LCD screen in just 10
years
Sam's are good to be the world's largest
manufacturer of LCD panels Samsung even
survived the 1997 Asian financial crisis
however Samsung was forced to sell
Samsung motor to Renault at a
significant loss on top of this samsung
even manufactured a range of aircrafts
the co-founder company named ka I along
with Daewoo Heavy Industries and a
Hyundai space in aircraft company today
Sam sexto manufactures aircraft engines
and gas turbines Samsung opened up a
computer programing laboratory in Warsaw
Poland in 2000 and slowly transitioned
into digital and smartphones and soon
enough Samsung came out with their first
smartphone the Samsung Solstice line of
devices and other variations in 2008
this eventually evolved into galaxies
and outlines in 2011 Samsung saw their
hardest drive business to Seagate and at
the beginning of that year Samsung
became the world's largest mobile phone
maker by unit sales and overtook Nokia
who had dominated the market since 1998
however it wasn't all good news for
Samsung in 2012
nine American jurors ruled that Samsung
had to pay Apple one point zero five
billion dollars for violating six of
Apple's patents on smart phone
technology but even after this Apple
wasn't satisfied Apple attempted to ban
the sale of eight Samsung phones which
included phones like the galaxy s2 and
galaxy s so showcase however this did
not work out Apple's favor in 2013 a new
zealand news outlet reported that many
Samsung washing machines spontaneously
caught on fire in 2014 Samsung
officially shut down their streaming
service
music cub however at the same time
Samson would still make a huge strides
forward in the same year
Samson I was a gear VR there are
fourteen point seven billion dollar
investment to build a chip plant in
South Korea and master plan the domestic
five hundred sixty million dollars into
the construction of a new 700,000 square
meter production complex in Vietnam saps
I've also revealed your upcoming service
tabs like 360 services finally they also
announced that they're going to sell
fiber optics to coming Inc in 2016
saps I can release a fitness Mart watch
called the gear fit - and wireless
earbuds name the gear icon acts however
Samson was unaware that they were going
to face a huge issue later that same
year their Galaxy Note 7 smartphone was
notorious for producing excessive heat
which even led to fires and explosions
as a result Samson recalled these notice
just a month after its release
Samson brought out a new version of the
galaxy note 7 but those two were played
with the same issue as its predecessor
and Samson ultimately halted production
of this book all together throughout
Samson continued releasing phones and
fortunately these worked much better for
them today
Samson has a huge slew of businesses
including Samsung Electronics
Engineering
Everland find chemicals industries
insurance and countless books and have
been able to pull in $6,500 every second
so what happens next for Samsung well
they just cruise through phones launches
and solidify the position or will they
attempt something creative and invest in
space exploration or something like that
make sure to post what you guys think is
next for Samsung also make sure to drop
a like if you guys enjoyed this video
and make sure to subscribe to discover
there are so many more companies but
until next time bye
[Music]